[Applause]
what's up GQ this is DJ Khaled father
Mossad welcome to my office
these are my essentials first up a
picture of my son and my queen
we have many pictures in my office with
my son and my cleaning my family that's
very important we're saying you know I
just got my mom's house and I still
pictures of me when I was a kid and
always only have mom and dad's house so
I was like you know what we're gonna get
so many pictures so my son grow up he
gets to see every stage in life of this
age and that his dad is bringing a
beautiful energy in the whole house it's
your family another family next up is
the father of assad threes collaboration
with Jordan these are very rare Jordan
has like a hundred pair and I'll have a
hundred pair suede leather on the
details on this the covers amazing one
side has we the best the Mossad has
Jordan and it's special you're saying
it's called the father of Assad threes
so this means a lot you know and that is
that I love Jordans the threes are my
favorite
nuts you got is the supreme charger
supporting that I have a charger for my
phone at all times because I have to
make sure that I'm always in
communication with my son and my queen
my family but also my fan love worldwide
you know I got to hit him with the snap
I gotta hit him with the aichi I got an
update on what's going on so I used my
social media for positivity motivation
in the inspiration and obviously we need
this for communication I've kind of
flowed in it no flow I'm not supreme I
love what they do but at the same time
this was a gift so I'm always been
useless we also have the Wii the best
charger now this one is my favorite
charger but also use it so that people
see that logo sit on the desk and then
Oh charge up ASAP - I'm saying this is
the Quran and the Quran everywhere I go
obviously this is on my guest
protective lessons protect the energy
and this is the Koran the Holy Quran
yeah you're saying my family my mom made
sure I have Quran is everywhere I'm
saying and I'm on blast man blessing
supporter have some fresh flowers every
week you know say outside I love nature
also inside I love nature too so it's
important to have beautiful flowers on
my desk around the house in the bathroom
it's just important that's to survive
see my shirt for shirt that flowers
I love truck my favorite flowers I got a
lot of them I can't pronounce that one
but what's the code oh honey bogan beat
I can't say say laughing with the Saints
fans playing say one more time yeah I
like those next up I don't know if you
wanna call these asteroids but your life
just ain't gonna lay on your desk or a
table
I need a Versace I got these is a gift I
always liked them you saying cuz I would
put my change from my pocket or put like
my keys on top of it you know like stuff
in your pocket
I would lay it on top of these things
and I'll just be like okay I gotta look
at these at all times it's rich it's
elegant its fly you know speaking of
Versace I love my Versace pillow I had
this in my car at all times I just
always have it like dad I'm chilling
it's like a silk vibe no I'm seeing a
bunch of pictures always told me pulling
pillows I love pillow did I keep this in
the car mom I think my brother Chris
Mokes got me that shoutout Chris smokes
we the best own family for life
[Music]
I love candles but this is my favorite
candle it's the day did I want to say
right is it key the dip teak on the bay
flavors my favorite candle I get these
at the geek store they love me I know
when I walk in I want a tall load up
if you follow my career you know I love
these and have you ever been in my house
or my office you know I love these when
I'm on tour my dressing room be having
them it's part of my Ryder it's
important
[Music]
soap is key and I've dubbed yoga and
Dove soap I'm surprised me and diving
did something together would be the
biggest gov ever cuz I really loved of
soap and tub to yoga and also love
I love cocoa butter this is my son's
cocoa butter I just love the way it
smells
I put it on every day I'm saying okay we
smoked earlier Meister cocoa butter
since I'm a kid I've always used cocoa
butter and my skin really loves it
always gotta have some cocoa butter when
my son was born they sent us up a care
package of just pictures of my son on it
and we appreciate it man the baby mobile
is with a little baby mama it's
important to have a bag secure the bag
alert protect the bag and secure the bag
and I'm saying I like this was my
favorite new bag I'm blessed to have a
few colors Oh some more colors I love
this collection shot a Virgil now he's
at the lowest or right when they come in
I get him inside collect bags I like him
laying around in my office I like them
laying around my closets like bags right
this moment these are my favorite
collection of bags but my favorite
favorite bag is the brown paper bag
brown paper bag thank God for that brown
paper bag that's the bag there's another
bag to that does it come in a bag it's
called a wire and that's a bad too
[Music]
these are my essentials thank you for
watching his father beside DJ Calvin
Billy Khaled Khaled another one